Tại vì thú khách sân nghiệp tham gia đầu tư xe dự nhà ở sả hội, nghị quyết thí điểm về một số cơ trề chính sách đặc thú
và chiến nhà ở sả hội vừa được cuối hội thông qua đã các sạm cây cách nhiều tụ tục hành chính.
Theo đó, sẽ cho phép thực hiện dào chủ đầu tư không thông qua đầu tổ.
Mò tụ tục thầm định bảo cao nghen kiêu khả thí đầu tư xe dự.
Không yêu cầu thực hiện bước lập, thầm định, phê dựt giễm vụ quý hoại chi tiết.
Không yêu cầu phải thực hiện quy chính đấu thông giống giải đối với các hỏi thầu lựa trọn nhà thầu trong khoản động xe dựa
mà đường áp dụ quy chính chỉ định thổ xuất hỏi. Mẹn dày phép xe dựa đối với trường hợp áp dụ thích kế mẫu, tích kế định hình.
Ngị quyết khổ quy định không yêu cầu thầm định giá bán, giá thêm mua nhà ở sả hội tại các quan trinh muôn cấp tính mà só chủ đầu tư tựa xe dựa.
Phê dựa. Sau khi hoàn thành, bán rao đưa vào sự dụ, chủ đầu tư có chế nghiệm thực hiện kiểm toán,
quyết toán và người hủ sơ đến cơ quan trinh muôn cấp tính đựa kiểm tra. Đồng thời,
nghị quyết bổ xuống trách nhiệm của chính phủ trong việc phòng gửa sơ hợp tham nhúng,
têu cờ, lắng phí, chục lợi chính sách và kìm sốt, kiểm tra, kiểm định chất lượng nhà ở sả hội.